chaz is a man's man okay that's what i
see he's a man's man
i come from a lineage of man's man it's
different when you are around man's man
the language is different the swagger is
different the respect is different the
expectation is different
things that don't matter to the average
person is going to matter a little bit
more to the man's man there's certain
things you can't cross the line on
certain things with them there are
certain things that's respect
thoughts
on
you with movies movies have a lot of
power right john q was the first movie
where i sat there and i said man that
kid should have had a heart man what are
we going to do with this quarter million
dollars that cost to get that hard like
what do we do with health insurance
there's influence with movies right
last 20 years men in movies are like you
know
presented as weak fragile pansies
softies you know
uh being pushed around you know they're
they're a joke they're a laughing stock
how much of this uh
direction we're going in the way we're
shaping and presenting how men are
are we losing the concept of man's man
because today masculinity is a little
bit frowned upon like if you're you're
too much of a man's man it's kind of
like well that's not respectful well
that's not this and you become almost
the target so how does a man's man today
um
survive in a era where it's frowned upon
to be a man's man
i you know what it's a good question
patrick
people you know women complain about
chivalry and i sometimes i would say
well you're the one who killed it
you know don't complain about it you
know i remember i was trying to
i was on a i was on a plane and the
woman uh
she had her stuff there and yeah it was
kind of she was struggling to get it off
the top and i i said excuse me i said
i'll get a feel honey i just meant i
said honey yeah and she said excuse me i
could do it and i'm not honey
i said oh i'm i'm sorry you know and she
kind of yelled it like not yelled at but
people hurt yeah yeah and i was just oh
okay i'm sorry and i was like wow
i was trying to help her good luck then
i i didn't mean anything by that i
wasn't saying hey honey i just said no
oh excuse me honey i'll get it for you
you know as being a man yeah and she
like jumped on my case you know i'm not
your honey and i could get it
and i was like whoa wow well you being
in hollywood what's your take on the me
too movement feminism i'm curious enough
if he goes deeper on that are you going
to go deeper on that because you're a
pretty pretty deep guy because i'm
sitting there having a conversation and
i say hey ladies can we do this and
we're at a restaurant say hi ladies and
one the girl says don't call me a lady i
said i'm i'm sorry what can i call you
right you just can call me a woman i'm a
woman i'm not a lady i said
so i step back i'm like i'm trying to
see why so can i ask you just for my own
curiosity
says if i'm a lady you're a lord you're
not a lord i said once
there's nothing you could say yeah yes i
mean you got to walk away yeah i don't
know i did i
walked when i had my food but the point
is you know like you you
you uh uh uh it's almost uh you're a
target today that's all i'm saying yeah
i feel bad for those people because it's
a lot of it is coming from like
internalized hatred and stuff that they
don't you know it's it's a way for them
i don't think it's internalized you
don't think so no i don't think this is
a way for them to feel powerful in ways
that they don't feel powerful and
they're
you know i'm just imagine having to go
through life and everything has to be
filtered through the lens of how can i
make this
about me how can i make this about this
offends me you you should have known
this way that's that's hot no that's
todd bro i'm sorry i can't buy that i
think that is taught there's we spent an
hour and 30 minutes so far in this
podcast talking about the value of
somebody teaching you good or bad
principles and then he said 100 percent
is parenting i says i don't know if it's
100 let's say it's 90 parenting let's
put the number on whatever ratios we
want to use
i think that is taught through a
generation and you think it's normal
it's very simple it's taught and i i
haven't i'm having a hard time with that
because for my kids you know what you
know one of my kids something happened
was a bully and they said yeah
in school this one school they were
going to in school daddy they're telling
us even if somebody hits you never hit
back so i said yeah really yeah i said
listen here's what we're gonna do i'ma
call your teacher so i called the
teacher and i went and met the school i
went and had everybody that said so
here's what i'm being told i just want
to manage the expectation because we
have to be on the same page because you
know as teachers and parents we're on
the same team we're trying to raise good
citizens right says yeah of course yes
fantastic i said so
this kid is bullying my son
okay
he's being told to just come and tell
you guys so he's being taught to snitch
which is fine okay but i'm just trying
to understand this
i said is that what feedback is being
told yes now what is the limit of
limitation you guys have here for how
much he has to accept bullying until he
punches back no we don't tolerate that i
said okay so we have a challenge here so
what's that because my kids come home
and my kids are instructed that if
somebody bullies you respectfully you
tell them to stop okay and you address
it and then if it happens continuously
you have to punch him in the face that's
a specific instruction somebody may
disagree with the sense that this is not
the right way to do right you have to do
in every possible way to avoid conflict
but you got to stand up
and then they're going back and forth
well that's not the right way of
parenting i said i'm sorry i'm not going
to raise little pansies yeah
here let me tell you why
let me tell you why
when i went
after my parents got a divorce and i
lived in germany and there was no father
figure
and it was me my sister and my mom and
they're both attractive yeah
the world is an ugly world if you're
going to be soft they're going to devour
you
so you want me to raise kids that are
going to be bullied the rest of their
life hail to the effing no it's not
going to happen right
so that's the part where i'm asking
because
you know like imagine if your son hangs
out with him for three months yeah what
do you think is going to happen
no honestly i want you actually thinking
but you got a kid he hangs out with
chess for three months what do you think
happens to your son
she comes smooth
forget about being smooth yeah he's
gonna learn the right way to actually
learn values and principles of what it
is to be a man right that's the
challenge i'm having i don't know if you
have anything i am so no i am so proud
of my son i have a son dante who's 25
years old
six two like you know me
dropped dead handsome built stud fud he
could fight
i i taught him how to fight just like my
dad taught me how to fight since he's
three years old like boxer dante
when we get off camera i'll show you
some things my son could fight and he
could and and but you know what i always
told him i always said to him dante when
he was young i'm teaching you how to
fight so you don't fight remember that
i know that my son is a stand-up
graduated berkeley
he'll he'll walk away but let me tell
you something but if you push it
he will he will put you out he will mma
you know the whole thing all you have to
do is build a reputation once yes you
have to you have to teach a person to
fight you have to if i have a son
if i had another son i would teach him
and i and my grandfather taught my
father my father taught me i thought my
son and my son will teach his kids not
just a boy a girl too no i'm doubt
that's what i was going to ask on the
other side of it you guys are both
fathers to daughters
so if somebody comes up something like
somebody at school made an unwanted
advance on your daughter and she came
home dad how do i handle it what do you
what are you telling her well i i wanted
to go to someone and tell them and see
how they handle it just like patrick did
if they handle it the right way and say
hey
you did it once you never do it again
because if you do it you're going to get
expelled yeah then his boy doesn't have
to worry but if this boy keeps doing it
and they keep telling this kid you can't
do anything back no no no that's i grew
up where a guy was a bully yeah you want
to be a bully boom let's go for it yeah
you know what it stopped it was over no
more bullying fights in the school yeah
it only takes a couple times the world
the world is an ugly place
people feed off you you gotta and if
they see weakness they keep it up
they keep it up i had a thing a year ago
i don't get into fights anymore i have
two i have two off-duty cops that travel
everywhere with me and they'll stop it
but this one guy i was sitting standing
at the bar and he came over me goes he
goes yeah you were here three weeks ago
i saw you
you remember me and i did remember him
because i was with a table and he walked
over and said hey i love your movies and
i said thank you
and he pulls up a chair and sits down i
mean you don't do that and i said excuse
me
i'm i'm with a party here i i thank you
that you love my movies but i'm sorry
i'm i'm with people and he got up and
left so then three weeks late he sees me
he comes he goes yeah you dissed me last
week a few weeks ago i said i what
he goes you diss me i go look i was with
a party and you came over i'm sorry you
know he goes yeah well i didn't like
that
and i could feel my the guy who's with
me holding my arm my one of my
bodyguards
and he goes wait i go i told them just
wait a second i said look if i did do
something i apologize i'm very sorry i
didn't i don't think i did but if i did
i truly apologize
and he said yeah well you know what
that's not enough and i says well then i
don't know what to tell you that and he
was a big guy you know and then he leans
over to me at the bar
and he says you know
i'm a [ __ ] tough guy says this to me
so now all of a sudden i went way back
in the street i went all of a sudden i
said okay i know what i'm dealing with
now i said that's good
i said because i'm a [ __ ] tough guy
too
so what do you want to do
and he went to me looked at me and went
come on i'm key and he went i'm just
teasing you hey man oh i really love
your movie i you know i said all right
we're cool man and he walked away
he pushed me to the point where i had to
show him
hey man
you want to play make him move let's go
until i did that
until i did that
he would have kept going yeah how long
ago was this by the way about a year ago
a year ago a year ago no i thought he
said three weeks ago you brought up uh
you reminded me of a story um respect
chess no no it but it's not it's just
come on guys yeah yeah that's enough
yeah do everything you can to avoid the
fight you know in the school you hope to
have a law and order where it doesn't
even come to you some schools do great
but the kids are going to the school
right now we had an incident they didn't
even make it up to me that i needed i
didn't need to go to school they handled
it themselves
see i i was i was taught wrong
like you guys are right but i was all
wrong but uh i'll never forget i was in
first grade and uh there was a kid named
matt and he was uh he was he was kind of
a bully my mom was a the lunch uh what
would it call like they come and they
like lunch lady one lunch lady but
they're like uh ladyland wasn't a lunch
lady they like uh cafeteria worker no
they like chaperone door and recess or
whatever like whatever so this the guy
calls him
he my mom tells the kid this they
stopped doing what he's doing he was
like pinching a girl or something like
that and i was like matthew stop and he
goes shut up [ __ ] to my mom and i was
like oh like you don't do that to my mom
like my mom's a warrior woman dude like
oh
and then
i come home my dad's never home he
worked in the city he was home at 8
o'clock at night when i come home my
dad's waiting for me at home and goes
hey did matt call your mom a [ __ ] today
at school i was like yeah i can't
believe he goes what'd you do i was like
nothing right he was like okay this is
what you're gonna do as soon as you get
off the bus tomorrow you're gonna walk
up the mat you're gonna punch him in the
face you're gonna keep punching until
you can't punch anymore
and i'm like i don't think i'm allowed
to do that he goes you're allowed to do
that go do that so first thing i get off
the bus in the morning i go and i punch
this kid i beat the living crap at him
i'm crying while i'm on top of him the
whole time i obviously get dragged to
the principal's office prince was like
what the heck was that about i was like
ah he called my mom a [ __ ]
so my dad's there obviously call that
work he's there he goes gerard i am so
disappointed in you this is not how i'm
like sitting there like shocked like
what the
what just happened here he comes out and
he goes hey free day off and he pounds
me we go get ice cream he takes me to a
yankee game that night
he was like look man
sometimes there's there's
there's a part of that that's not
your dad didn't do you wrong dude
there's a part of that that's kind of
like
you know he he taught you to protect
your mom and your two sisters you got
two sisters right right there was a
better way to go about it i'm not saying
listen the one thing about parenting
that sucks is there's no freaking manual
you know you you can say the bible yes
there's a but there's not a manual that
says
if this thing happens what do you do go
to page 396 to see seven steps on how to
handle this you kind of gotta freaking
go off the cuff so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]